como una pista voy a sacar el
determinante de una matriz muy parecida
ok de esta matriz b que es 53 menos 14
entonces para sacar el terminante de
esta matriz voy a escribir por acá 53
menos 14 y le voy a poner los símbolos
de determinante y este determinante es
igual a tomar esta diagonal y
multiplicar la ósea tenemos 5 por 4 y
después muy importante restarle lo que
nos quede de la multiplicación de esta
otra diagonal ok le vamos a restar lo
que nos quede de multiplicar 3 x menos 1
es por menos 1 entonces 5 por 4 lo que
nos queda es 20 y luego menos 3 por
menos 1 eso lo que nos queda es menos 3
no entonces lo que queremos es restar
menos 3 pero menos -3 eso es más 3 no
entonces aquí nos queda más 3 y
finalmente nos queda 20 más 3 ó 20 menos
-3 y eso es igual a 23
entonces el determinante de b es igual a